created of haste
What's
meant is this is a
figurative statement which is
used to articulate that the
human being is very hasty. The
human being is so hasty and
always in a rush even when it's
detrimental to him. The human
being is in such a rush and
always hasty and that that is
the nature of the human being.
So much so. That it could be
said the human being was
created from haste. The human
essential material is that of
haste itself. This of course is
to articulate the embedded
nature of the human being to be
hasty. Constantly in a rush
even when this is something or
even especially when this is
something that
harmful to the person. We
understand from this verse, the
human being has been created
from haste or has been created
of haste. What we understand
from this is that haste is the
nature of the human being. And
anything that is your nature,
it takes extreme amounts of
discipline to practice
otherwise. We understand from
something being our nature that
it doesn't go away ever. It
will never be gone. So, for
instance, It is part of a
person's a human being's nature
to be ungrateful. It is part of
a human being's nature to be
hasty. It is part of the human
being's nature to be selfish,
etcetera. These things are your
nature. Now, how do we change
these things? These things will
not change. Rather they will.
What we do is we practice their
opposites. So, we learn the
discipline of patience. We
learn the discipline of
gratitude. We learn the
discipline of
We learn the discipline of
patience and gratitude and all
of these things that are
contrary to our nature. But
even if we learn and master the
art of or the discipline of
patience for instance. This
doesn't mean that haste has
gone away. No, it's still there
and if you stop practicing
patience, you lose it. You lose
that discipline. This is the
meaning of something being in
nature. Just because something
is your nature doesn't mean
that you can't do to what's
contrary, you can. That's
called discipline And
discipline can go away at any
time when you stop practicing
it. Just a must
just a muscle. If a person
stops practicing a muscle, it
will atrophy. It will recede
and the person's muscle will
deplete due to lack of use and
lack of practice. So, when
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us that the human being has
been created from haste,
meaning that it's the human
nature to be hasty, to be
impatient. And a person the art
and the discipline of patience
but they will never be
completely rid of it. They will
always have to continue to
exhibit more patience and
discipline themselves to
patients until they reach a
level of mastery in that and
even when they reach the level
of mastery, impatience, its
will, it will always be
impatience, will always be
around the corner. So, a person
has to be aware of this. All
subhanahu wa ta'ala says I
shall soon show you my
evidences, my signs, so do not
hasten me. I shall soon show
you my signs. What is meant by
that? Meaning thee, miracles,
the signs of the
validity of the prophet
Muhammad prophethood. And some
of the scholars of Tafsir
mentioned that here my signs is
a reference to the punishment
of Allah that they continue to
ask for in mocking the prophet
they'll say if you're true if
you if if this is true if you
really are a prophet and if we
disagree with you or disbelieve
in you we will be punished,
then punish us. Let's see. So,
they continue to say this to
the prophet
in a mocking way. with an air
of mockery and Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala responds to this
saying, the human being has
been created from haste. I
shall show show you my signs so
do not hasten me.
And they say, in mocking the
prophet
when
is this alleged day of
resurrection going to be or day
of punish going to be, if you
are, if you are truthful in
what you're saying. Meaning,
the prophet says, the day of
resurrection is swiftly
approaching, the day of
judgement is swiftly
approaching, we must prepare
ourselves, we must turn to
Allah, we must be grateful to
Allah, and they respond to this
by saying, when is this day
going to be? In a mocker, in in
a mocking way. subhanahu wa
ta'ala says and comments on
this statement and this
attitude in general. He says,
if the those who disbelieved
truly knew
the severity of
A day of punishment that would
come when the fire would be
placed on their backs and on
their faces and they would not
be able to. They would not be
able to shield their backs or
their faces from this fire.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
if they knew this, they would
not say such a thing. They
would not hold such a
disposition. Allah says about
the day of resurrection, they
say, when is this day? When is
this punishment? Allah responds
and says, rather, this
punishment will come. Suddenly,
it will come. Suddenly, and
when it comes, it will confuse
them. And they will neither be
able to repel this punishment
from themselves. Nor will they
be? Given any extension of time
to repent to Allah or to seek
forgiveness when it comes, it
comes, that's it. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says to the
prophet
and indeed, messengers who have
preceded you, have been mocked,
as you have been mocked. And
that which they made a mockery
of, did befall Meaning, those
who mock the prophets and
messengers, what they were
making a mockery of, actually
happened and was realized in
their world and took hold of
them. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says to the prophet to say to
them, Who is this? Who is going
to protect you? whether in
night or in day from a Rahman.
Who can protect you? You
worship other than Allah. You
worship idols. And not only
that but you make fun of the
prophet and his followers for
the most distinct of their
virtues. What is the greatest
virtue of the prophet Muhammad
What is the greatest virtue of
the prophet greatest virtue is
his worship of Allah alone
without any partners. This is
greatest virtue. By this is
what Allah has raised him above
all others. The veracity and
the depth of his worship and
his Tawhid. And this is the
very thing that they mock about
him.
And they say this is the one
who says we should leave off
the worship of our Gods and we
should worship Allah alone they
make this kind of into a big
hee haw and a big joke and so,
they worship other than Allah
and they refuse to worship
Allah alone. And so, the
question is, who can protect
you in daytime or nighttime
from Al Rahman? Who can protect
you? The answer is obviously
noone. None can protect us from
Allah except for Allah himself.
Then, why do we other than
Allah. If all is caused by
Allah, if all is created by
Allah. and if none can protect
us from Allah, if Allah so
chooses to do something to us,
then why would we worship or
direct any of our worship of
gratitude to other than Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. This is
silly. This is illogical. Not
just haram but also illogical
and ridiculous.
Allah says
Meaning, if you were to say to
them, who protects you? Who can
protect you? At night or in
day, night or day from Al
Rahman, they will say, nobody
can protect us. Yet,
simultaneously as they say
this, they are disbelieving and
turn away from the worship of
their lord. They do not worship
their lord. What does that
mean? They do not worship their
lord. We know that they Allah
and they worship others along
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
that they worship Allah and
they worship idols as well.
They don't exclusively worship
idols. They worship Allah and
they worship idols. So, why is
it that Allah is saying that
they do not worship him? The
answer is that worship has to
be based on Tawhid. It has to
be based on worshiping Allah
alone. Just in order for
it to be considered salah a
person has to have and if a
person makes salah without
knowingly on purpose without an
excuse, their salah is not
considered salah. So, for
instance, if a person makes
the longest, most heartfelt,
beautiful salah you've ever
seen. but they make this salah
without on purpose. Say, I know
I should make wudu but I don't
want to make but then they
stand and make salah without
ubu. Would we call this salah?
No matter how good it is, no
matter how well it's done, is
it considered salah? No, it's
not considered salah. We, it
would be correct to say, he
didn't pray. Correct? You've
not prayed. Because it's
missing one of its key
elements. Likewise is the
situation with worship. If a
person worships Allah and
worships Allah with extreme
gratitude and worships Allah
with with humility and all of
these elements of worship but
they worship others along with
Allah. And we consider this
worship. No. This is not
worship. Because worship of
Allah is one of its conditions.
Is Tawheed just one of
Salah's conditions is? If a
person does not have will do,
they do not have salah. If they
do not have tawheed, they do
not have worship of Allah.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
or do they have gods that will
protect them from us? Any of
these gods that they worship
other than Allah? Are they
going to protect them from
Allah? Even they relent that
this is not possible. That
nothing can possibly protect
them from Allah. They they
believe this as well. So if you
believe this, why do you
worship other than Allah? He
regarding these these things,
these gods, these deities that
are worshiped aside from
himself These things and these
individuals who are worshiped
other than Allah, they do not
have the ability to give
victory to their own selves nor
are they able to protect others
from us. They can protect
themselves, let alone protect
anyone else. They don't have
the ability to do so. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
these things as a kind of
logical train of thought in
order for a person to arrive at
the conclusion that
the worship of Allah alone
without any partners is the
only way. It is the only
logical conclusion and if a
person arrives at that
conclusion, any other religion
will have an element of shirk
in it. It is only the religion
of Islam that has pure,
protected, monotheism. And so
if a person understands this,
that it is only Allah that is
worthy of worship alone without
any partners truly and they
truly believe this. They can't
help but follow the prophet
[Arabic recitation]